john cusack has played some of the most
iconic roles of all time from say
anything to high fidelity bullets over
Broadway to Being John Malkovich Cusack
is charmed audiences for decades but
although the talented versatile actor
has been in the business over 30 years
his career isn't what it used to be why
let's take a look back and see why John
Cusack hasn't graced our screens for a
while he called Hollywood a whorehouse
in an interview with The Guardian about
his role in the Hollywood satire map to
the stars John Cusack came clean about
his views on the strange world of
Hollywood Hugh sack commented that the
old ways of filmmaking are gone and now
everything revolves around franchises
and huge stars which isn't really all
that off the mark as he puts it the
culture just eats young actors up and
spits amounts it's a hard thing to
survive without finding safe harbor it's
easy to understand his seeming
hesitation to fight for stardom in an
industry he's lost trust in considering
his views on Hollywood he went on to
describe it by saying
Hollywood is a whorehouse and people go
mad writing films not content to be just
an actor Hugh Sakas co-written a few of
his most popular films he co-wrote the
screenplays for high fidelity and a
Grosse Pointe blank proving that he
knows a few things about dark comedy and
oddball characters - they listen to pop
music because I was miserable
what were they miserable because I
listen to pop music more recently he
co-wrote the political film war ink as
well as we are not animals which is
fittingly a film about an actor getting
tired of Hollywood though it doesn't
look like he has any new screenplays in
the works as of the making of this video
he still been writing quite a bit the
only difference is he's turned his
writing efforts to the political arena
politically active John Cusack isn't
your typical actor interested in the
political world when Visa MasterCard and
PayPal all stops taking payments
intended for WikiLeaks in 2010 Cusack
became a founding member of the freedom
of the press foundation in response the
Foundation's main goal is to protect the
privacy of the journalists willing to
deal with potentially dangerous subjects
it's an advocacy group just trying to
protect the right fruit
from journalists to do their job protect
their sources through crowdfunding they
help different press organizations stay
afloat regardless of outside pressures
Cusack has written many articles for the
site and is clearly passionate about the
issue of freedom of speech Hugh sack has
also written over 20 articles for the
Huffington Post and in 2014 he travelled
to Russia with arundhathi Roy and Daniel
Ellsberg to meet with Edward Snowden Roy
and Cusack wrote a series of essays
about their conversations with Snowden
which they formed into the book things
that can and cannot be said Jew suckas
still devoted to activism and it's
obvious he's not happy just resting on
his celebrity he wants to make a real
difference and with so much time spent
in the political arena it's no wonder he
doesn't light up the marquee as much
anymore
aging out of the rom-com Hugh Sachs
started out as a teenage heartthrob
playing the sweet a slightly nerdy guy
who'd do anything for his girl
yeah Rosario mom who are perky but
nobody can play the handsome leading man
forever though Cusack often branched out
to do less mainstream work like a Being
John Malkovich and a Midnight in the
Garden of Good and Evil he kept taking
lead roles and those movies got worse
and worse at least according to critics
and the box office receipts sure he's
got high fidelity but he also made must
love dogs
serendipity and America's Sweethearts
and you didn't even realize those clips
were out of order and he definitely
wasn't an American Beauty American
Beauty what's funny about that
you Redman know what welcome you to look
it seems that mainstream Hollywood wants
to put him in leading roles and dull
action flicks or rom-coms burrows Cusack
who clearly wants to go in a different
direction like the killer roles he
played in the frozen ground and the
paperboy when Hollywood only wants to
see play the same thing over and over
again
it's no wonder Cusack is a little
hesitant to keep taking on huge leads
straight to DVD Hugh sack hasn't been in
as many blockbusters as he used to but
that doesn't mean he's given up acting
in fact Cusack's been making tons of
movies between 2012 and 2016
he made a whopping 17 films the reason
you might not be aware of that insane
productivity is that most of the film's
wind up going straight to video
on-demand or DVD
they tend to be well unimpressive like
reclaim or the fake sounding drive hard
four of his films since 2014 got critics
ratings below 5 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes
that's full-blown Nicolas Cage territory
just kidding
Nic Cage is in a league of his own
critically ignored that's not to say
that John Cusack's recent movies are all
bad in 2015 he starred in love and mercy
as an older Brian Wilson frontman for
the Beach Boys dealing with mental
illness and the controlling manager the
film received excellent reviews with
many praising Cusack's fine work in
particular but the film only made twelve
million dollars domestically and though
there was some speculation about a
potential Oscar nomination Huw sac came
up short he wasn't nominated for a
single award the entire season and the
film itself was similarly shut out
things to come though it may seem like
Hugh Sachs star is dimmed all that's
really done is split into a
constellation of different projects John
Cusack won't be fading into the
background anytime soon his political
writing and activism will surely keep
him busy in the next few years and he's
already got another film lined up with
more than 30 years in the acting
business we're pretty sure he's got more
than a few more iconic parts up his
sleeve thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]